Josh Shaw hey rap good morning good
morning you are no longer with this at
gamespot unfortunately but you are a
star wars fan like myself yeah and so I
called you up and we're gonna watch the
rogue one trailer the first time it's
been a rough morning of not watching it
yo let's look at it and see what it
looks like that's good here we go here
we go all audiences state your name for
the record gen also forgery of Imperial
documents possession of stolen property
aggravated assault resisting arrest on
your own from the age of 15 reckless
aggressive and undisciplined this is a
rebellion isn't it oh damn I rebell
she just a little punk we have a mission
for you Wow a major weapons to hunt we
need to know what it is how to destroy
it clear yes what will you do wouldn't
it catch you what will you do if they
break you
if you continue to fight
haha
oh my god dude okay let's go back now
Josh and uh take a look at this piece by
piece so we have here I love like
revisiting the themes in making these
dramatic versions of them she's a
prisoner forgery of it which was you
know she she's she's a war criminal aids
a trash can but yeah there's a couple of
these gonk gonk gonk like my working
theory is she kind of got arrested after
may be causing that trouble earlier okay
so let's pause it here we've we've got a
full throwback set here totally we got
Mon Mothma who is never she wasn't in it
till Return of the Jedi this is the
actress and she was in a revenge of the
sith and damn if she doesn't look
exactly like the one from Return of the
gentleman carrying a real cool job of
matching that up so yeah it's cool you
were seeing looks like this guy over on
the left to be a rebel general right
like an acabar yeah I mean this is yet
early early stages of the Rebel Alliance
they're just like they're just a militia
they turn into like a government with
leaders but now it's like full military
except for mon mothma it looks like I
saw that guy's got like claritin close
at hand so she's rocking like these
batons I think it's just one rut one at
the moment it's like a nightstick really
yeah
okay and you point this out dude so yeah
frame by frame sorry go for it BAM this
guy in the lower left or girl has what
looks like a detonator and I've blown up
some minds on the tank that we see later
you can exactly right so looks like I
mean basically they set an ambush up and
you know this is maybe kind of a
precursor to them all getting busted
later on so he this I I would guarantee
you she's she's cat held captive written
in this moment she's looking out like
I've transport oh yeah so fresh out of
the factory it looks like 3d printed or
something yeah right they just made that
so yeah I mean uh some subtle changes to
the Star Destroyers now right there's
like a little bit of like a UH something
on top of the deck so it's so cool about
these movies is like they're like
generational like throughout the years
you see this [ __ ] change so many ways
there's bigger ones obviously in force
awakens there's a whole new class mm-hmm
so let's talk about this uh you
mentioned and this is canon now that
this is this Death Star the first Death
Star essentially was like outsourced to
different planets or manufacturers right
well just the scale of any thing like
this would have to be built across it
would take like a huge effort this was
what the Emperor was like focused on so
yeah in the book Tarkin he was assigned
to a remote moon secret project which is
coordinating the construction of the
desta and were they doing that also in
in the process of hiding the full-scale
that a star like hey you build the left
side and like as and no one really knew
what exactly they're building there's
building a piece yeah I mean from what I
understand is most people weren't aware
of the full project so that's why
something like plans is so important but
I doubt it's like build the left side
it's like build some giant reactor right
I'm do sure but I mean that gun looks
like here you build the gun yeah okay so
this you know this remind me of it is
like the first photo of this movie was
that that set photo he looked like it
was literally done in the
hanger yeah I mean a probably cuz yeah
it was classic little game East elastic
alarm he got gunk in the back on honk
walking around charging things he's just
a battery right he's a walking batteries
hezar garcias of course yes this guy who
uh this is a cool scene right so we have
this hologram in the back which is very
very reminiscent to like the display in
Return of the Jedi okay but let me float
some by you that doesn't look like the
Death Star though it's like not
symmetrical it's not orderly that looks
like a planet like this could be in the
Death Star looking at a hologram of a
planet or something that's a good point
I yeah I guess cuz that look at the
frame of that window behind him in the
floor like this is an imperial place I
mean obviously that's not Yavin or
something and I mean to me what are
these Lots mean these are these are also
lines like you see a lot of lines here
planets don't have lines do they I mean
yeah okay I mean so maybe it's you
you're out you're on something I mean
that it's it's still a confirmed right
right that's a good it's not like
definitely desktop so now this guy is I
mean even though he's wearing white he's
got to be high ranking Imperial it could
be like um from a different military arm
you know navy army Marines like maybe
he's just a high-ranked Admiral or
something I posted something else but
this this moment is real cool it's a you
know too slow dolly in he's rocking a
pistol this is like to me it's implying
bring him to me so I can execute so and
so you know like this this is this is
just death so there's that tank that
totally was one that blew up later or
earlier excuse me with that kind of
turrets on the side there yeah so that's
kind of before they actually hit their
plan so that that's an interesting
character yeah at the suit but what can
we do but speculate I mean to me it kind
of seems like he could have some limbs
replaced by cybernetics has kind of the
that look and feel to it because it's
such a bulky suit it looks like it's
more than armor but we'll just have to
wait and see on that when I guess
do wouldn't it got you so yeah this
thing you have this a kind of pole
look-alike soposed dad it's a cannon
that he fought in the Battle of Endor
mm-hmm like who knows when he started
mm-hmm could be in this would make got
you so this is uh this is the robot on
the left is played by alan tudyk who is
a very funny actor he's done you know he
was in serenity and firefly i think we
mentioned like you can expect some you
know some light-hearted lines from him
as a character Danny I think was the one
he said this is so Allah this was shot
in London this is like totally subway
right yeah that's like it looks like
apparently people from London recognize
it yeah they just took down all the
signs for the underground right all
right so you got some you know like the
stormtrooper clone war way you got some
camo on some of these uh outfits and I
link types of troopers yeah and so these
guys are new right I think they could
even still be maybe they're on uh that
swamp planet in the end or like kind of
tropical area like yeah I mean they
could be speeder bikes all right so this
is awesome there's a lot going on in the
background as well the foreground
obviously we have a characters very
reminiscent of it like Japanese martial
artists in the background we have a
crashed black excellent this has kind of
been leaked before and set photos and
stuff oh look on the right it looks like
kind of parachute like oh dang he
overhang that a crash into it could be
that too um it'd be cool if it was kind
of like maybe he tried to slow his crash
or something so the character can't wait
to learn more about this character is
interesting right like people he really
does look like he's blind walking out
right you even there I feel like but I
mean granted that's it that's a
freeze-frame listening but I I think
he's got some cool power I'm so glad
they have the martial artist doing
martial arts in this movie as opposed to
just running away from rathtar's yeah
and you say the same about the you know
the hope of what the Knights of Ren
could have could have been and they hope
Neil Mabel see that next the next
episode 8 but yes you got no Jedi right
you gotta replace Jedi with something
and it's it's these guys these martial
artists that's great this is so this
whole scene or sequence is so World War
two Pacific Theater mm-hmm a hundred
percent I just I really think they went
for that you know like beach landings
and an island hopping like you I really
get that five like here like this
reminds me of like a flamethrower in you
know like okay now or something like
that yeah and that guy's helmet too it's
like you can see it so this is and this
is like Sun setting so this is the
aftermath of like the 80 80 s we see you
later on right this is after the battle
yeah okay so this is a big one
definitely you got Empress guards here
emperor in my opinion is in the room
right he's in the room you don't think
that's him with the robe I do and I
don't I mean I don't know but I just had
to say like why the hell is the Emperor
kneeling why would he Neil who's he
kneeling to that guy kneels to no one so
soften a mirror seems like it back to
tank which is the healing fluid from
Empire Strikes Back so maybe the
Emperor's in the tank but I really
really doubt that it could be a new
character could be Snoke more yeah i
mean the Imperial Guards they don't
guard Vader they don't guard anyone but
the Emperor so unless this is just
something that's completely new I think
that's got to be the Emperor so who
knows this is the edges I just thought
that was interesting and alluding to
something you know like what what is
going on with this white active this
respect you lating but like it might I
wouldn't be surprised in the movie if it
wasn't white like they just did that to
hide hide it for the trailer yeah
totally mostly baby snow kukri babies
know you're new to fight oh my god so
this dude's rumored to be like a weapons
expert right who knows and he's he's
part of that he's part of the clan the
squad yeah packing a tank of fuel maybe
that's a high-powered weapon or
something I mean it's a very very much a
red fit so I would imagine they're all
one the same if this is connected to the
next shot then they're basically running
from this bunker I really think it is
because here you got all these dead
dudes in the background well actually
last-ditch f
to survive because oh my god the shot is
so good tilt up still oh yeah oh it's
such a beautiful thing so they're like
yeah like I really think they're one the
same they are they are fleeing because
they're they've just been you know
cornered into a into a bunker either
they die in the bunker they die out here
right like here's this one on the right
not my favorite is this one on the
Rights closing in like they're so
surrounded yeah I'd love to see like an
aerial shot where they're just in a
circle around this bunker oh this is
this is the height of the Empire right
like they are just crushing everything
at this point yeah and like you know
also it's like you know that they aren't
really going to change anything in this
movie the Emperor's gonna stay strong
right they're gonna like really mess
with these guys too but at the end of
the day the heroes get that one little
floppy disk out mm-hmm look at this it
the vignette of the frame there too yeah
that could be from just a really wide
lens but it's probably in post such a
world war two grit that's that's this
whole scene it just reminds me yet again
like a pacific theater world war two on
Alderaan um yeah so keeping on moving on
photo yeah of course Jesus with this one
last shot I didn't realize these I
thought this was a dip to black but the
lights are turning on and even knows
that yeah she's turning around I wonder
if she sees Vader who she see but no
doubt uh this is a Imperial TIE fighter
uniform that's I really think this is
this is like the final stage and
stealing the plans is sneaking in
disguised as an imperial fighter she
they probably even hijacked a TIE
fighter right and landed whatever they
need to yeah in disguise just like a han
and luke disguises stormtroopers yeah
total little while back it's cool it's
is this is exciting this is a really
good trailer this this moment here was
awesome like what are they gonna do
anyways this is gonna be a good damn
move this is this is looking real good
you know
we basically rambled through that that
whole breakdown as we do them as we do
but thanks for watching and I think you
know next trailer will probably have you
come back in again Oh that'd be fun
alright well thanks for watching
everyone how you doing cool let's watch
it again yeah you want watch it again
yeah